it's time for roses and Rose a the
finale is over ah
guys I got a really fancy glass for the
finale of Nick Wilde season of The
Bachelor let's drink as much as we can
right now because things got awkward
okay
all right everybody so tonight was
Nick's
season of finale followed by the live
after the final rose special on the
finale we started off with Nick Vanessa
and Raven all say hello to his family
yet again to his adorable mom with her
vets and his adorable dad who is
apparently where Nick gets his tendency
to cry from which is very sweet but
Vanessa's talking to Nick's family and
having this really sweet moment and next
family is like Nick do something
make this is my new time initiative
because she's having along my heart I
have a lot of fun and that's the
beginning of the end
quite literally back to Finland
so [ __ ] spends time with both Raven and
Vanessa we're going to focus on Vanessa
first Nick spend some time with Vanessa
and makes an awkward joke about her side
I don't know how to go faster I'm not
just anyone general squeezes your
thoughts can do that because they were
in fantasy things together get it get it
they did it I guess okay and then and
then and then semantics have you seen
Santa
so Santa is lurking in the Flores and
Finland like an absolute serial killer
and even Santa's magic cannot save this
whole situation Nick and that has this
time together is full of a lot of non
romantic statement like this one that's
a matter of perspective and this one
when I've been with you I'm only fun of
you and this one on a d---rom gear off
unknown oh drink every time someone says
something that does not indicate a
successful relationships house I'm gonna
run out of wine and I needed eggs I'm
going to run out of wine and Vanessa
even asked Nick our minds attack babe
you are beautiful and smart and I like
you but each the finale why are we just
happy this question anything I could
over - Raven where things are easy this
is easier Raven easy breezy beautiful
proxy Arkansas literally everything is
like a pile of puppies Raven there were
actual puppies there I'm not joking I
hope my Kansas maker and cute as a
stuffing
the toughest thing about this night is
that naked injured can move my night
possibly from all the horizontal kissing
keys to do and make it right
taken so long affair my card up make it
to finale you've done this before
you should have known exactly how long
it would take you should know tygris
I felt like we were being made to
believe that Nick we made it a craven
but for the whole rest of the season I
was made to believe that Nicholas
College hmm enter Neil Lane and we're
and here's where Nick said something I
don't believe believe it or not I
actually know very little about
engagement rings you proposed twice
already
how many times are going to see you
again I'm still thinking that her all
right now we're going to propose Raven
arrived first so that means by Raven she
was so sweet and Hamlet so well and
looked so great and I love a fir moment
and just Raven you're wonderful and then
Vanessa arrives also looking great
he's gonna propose he proposed
Vanessa Grimaldi will you
marry Nick said he was trying to fight
that he loves Anessa
I tried to fight it but Wow why why no
explanation we just kind of been how
this season himself at the end to meet a
lot of strong action with little
explanation Vanessa says she's a happy
and she's ever been and they're gonna do
it
what go do it all right
literally with her strong sighs not
general squeezes her thought wonderful
and then and then and then we headed
over to after the final this is live and
things got weird first as usual things
with Raven are easy she comes on she's
super sweet you know I got something
going on this summer in Mexico we find
out he's going to Paradise wonderful I
will watch you Raven soon after Vanessa
comes out there has been days that have
been difficult vanessa is very honest
I'm not going to sugarcoat things I
don't blame her but as a viewer I want
to believe in the mystique a little bit
longer it's you know we've I love him we
love each other but it's a struggle
they've been fighting oh my god looking
back I wish I would have watched an
entire season before coming onto the
show you know things are going well when
you say we love each other but drink
every time it's awkward we're realistic
bottom line these two have no wedding
plans zero plans not even on their radar
they're just try to figure out who they
are and I'm like really
proud to be an American they're just
trying to figure out who the other
person is very approximate on finger hey
Ike but here is the beautiful gorgeous
fantabulous thing about this franchise
they still find a way to make you
believe in love and to reach to Lindsay
our hope for the future guys we have
been promised a historic bachelor first
and we got it I have to say the
Bachelorette starts right now
what happened was we met some of Rachel
Lindsay's contestants and I have to say
I got to myself Lou props I predicted
that this would be the situation though
I didn't know what they were going to do
was have these guys meet Rachel live on
air this is brilliant it's beautiful I
love it it makes me believe in love
again just in time for the new season of
The Bachelorette and I love briefly
Lindsay she is so poised and smart and
gorgeous and funny and I just cannot
wait for her to be the Bachelorette so
we only have four guys that was real
awkward I'm no need to go black and I'm
never going to go back but you know it's
these guys first time in life - no
judgement for them love it can't wait
for it they've restored in love yes
guys here's to the season of The
Bachelor into our new season of The
Bachelorette which were just roll look
right into
thank you so much for watching on roses
and Rosie all season long please let me
know any additional thoughts you have
over on social media do you think Nick
and Vanessa will make it will you be
voting for Nick on Dancing with the
Stars who could you see Raven ending up
woods and Paradise and do you think any
of those first four guys is the one for
Rachel so many questions again thank you
guys so much I really appreciate all of
your love and support and can't wait to
see my
[Music]